Italia da un giro a la extrema derecha
la líder del partido ultraconservador
hermanos e Italia Giorgio melón Y tomó
juramento como la primera mujer que
encabeza el gobierno de ese país
juro ser Leal a la República respetar
fielmente su Constitución sus leyes y
ejercer mi rol en los exclusivos
intereses de la nación
su ascenso fue celebrado por prominentes
figuras de la extrema derecha europea
como el Primer Ministro húngaro Víctor
Urban o la líder de la agrupación
nacional Marín le Peña en Francia dirige
una mujer pero está lejos de abrazar la
causa feminista 18 hombres y seis
mujeres integran su gabinete Aunque en
el pasado había dejado ver su simpatía
por una Italia fuera de la zona Euro
meloni ha designado a un Pro europeo
como jefe de la diplomacia el ex
presidente del parlamento europeo
Antonio tajani la presidenta de la
comisión europea Úrsula Wonder Legends
ha sido una de las primeras signatarias
en felicitarla y recordarle las tareas
conjuntas que hay pendientes y el
presidente estadounidense Joe biden
también ha citado los desafíos que
afrontan juntos en la otan en el
gabinete de melón y destaca Jean Carlos
georgetti ministro de economía un
militante moderado de la liga de salvini
partidario de la pertenencia a los 27 5
tecnócratas no afiliados a ningún
partido integran el gobierno de meloni
que ha tenido que imponerse a sus
compañeros de coalición Mate
ambos cercanos al kremlin y de hecho
marcar distancia con el ex Primer
Ministro luego de que se filtraran
audios en los que detallaba su amistad
con Vladimir Putin Y es que la cercanías
ideológicas no son garantía de una
administración unida melón y tendrá que
hacer frente esas diferencias para
llevar adelante su gobierno y cumplir
con sus promesas de campaña como aliviar
el golpe por los altos costos de la
energía reducir impuestos y evitar el
aumento de la edad pensional que
entraría en vigor en enero